there is this tiered system about who
gets it first the priority list if you
like
and within that there will be some big
questions for the government for the
department of health
about those with extra vulnerabilities
perhaps cancer other illnesses who will
be moved up the priority list
not necessarily according to their age
so it will be a difficult undertaking
but as you say a positive note overall
from the government today
and in terms of this vaccine and in
terms of people taking it
um the government is very keen to
reassure the population that it is
safe obviously the shot of the prime
minister
having a vaccination will be a one that
they will want to get out there but
equally
they won't want to bump him up the list
will they no it's a bit of a difficult
one when it comes to pr i think matt
hancock the health secretary offered to
do it live
on television earlier on today but there
is a question about
the safety of course there is people
want to know that everything has been
done correctly and we had that
reassurance today from the top experts
in charge of making sure that this is
ready to go they say the
reason why they've been able to approve
it so quickly is not because any corners
have been cut
and that's absolutely essential but
because they were preparing to do so
well ahead of time they were getting all
the steps in place
over the summer when they knew that a
vaccine was a possibility so they were
able to be quick off the mark
when it came to batch testing and
ultimately to approving it
the world health organization has now
actually asked for the data and
for some help if they can recommend and
approve the vaccine
themselves do anything they can to speed
up across the world and
crucially we heard from zakir stammer in
prime minister's questions today
the labour leader asked the prime
minister for a comprehensive
communication strategy
so that all mps across the house of
commons could say exactly the same thing
to the public
over the coming weeks because as you hit
on there really one of the most
important parts of this rollout will be
public trust
it will be ensuring that people know
they can take the vaccine safely
and that they can rely on it and those
tests to make sure that the antibodies
stay in people's system to measure how
long they are safe for how long they're
protected for
that will go on this the scientific side
of this is not ended by any means those
trials will continue over the next
couple of months
perhaps even the next couple of years so
a huge amount of work has gone into
making sure that all of this has been
done safely
matt hancock will reiterate that today
but expect to see that communication
strategy
from central government and perhaps even
the start of it this afternoon when the
prime minister gets up at that press
conference because that will be key
to make sure that people feel able to
take the vaccine and of course that's
crucial
to end some of these tough restrictions
and as well as reassuring
those that maybe don't want to take it
to take it the government also has to
uh reassure the rest of us to be patient
we'll leave that thought uh sadly we'll
get your response to it later
because matt hancock just about to
address the speaker
and mr speaker with permission i'd like
to make a statement virus vaccine
today marks a new chapter in our fight
against this virus
ever since the pandemic hit our shores
almost a year ago we have known that a
vaccine would be
critical to set us free so
all through this arduous year and it has
been an arduous year
while we've been working night and day
to fight the virus and
keep it under control we've been
striving to to develop the vaccines that
can give us hope
and let us eventually release the curbs
on our freedoms that have bound us for
so long
thanks to the incredible work of the
vaccines task force
the business secretary and kate bingham
we've already amassed a huge portfolio
of different
vaccine candidates we've backed seven
vaccines
and ordered 357 million doses on behalf
of the whole uk
one of the biggest portfolios per capita
in the world
we've said from the start that a vaccine
must be safe and
effective before we'd even consider
deploying it
any vaccine must go through a rigorous
process of clinical trials involving
thousands of people and extensive
independent scrutiny from the mhra
one of the world's most respected
medical regulators
today i'm delighted to inform the house
that the mhra has issued the clinical
authorization of the pfizer biontech
vaccine
this is a monumental step forward
it's no longer if there's going to be a
vaccine it's when
in our battle against the virus help is
on its way
today is a triumph for all those who
believe in science
a triumph for ingenuity a triumph for
humanity and i want to thank everyone
who's played their part in this
achievement
the team at pfizer the team of
scientists at beyond tech
the volunteers who stepped up and took
part in clinical trials
and to the mhra themselves who've made
sure
that this is a vaccine that we can all
have faith in
thanks to their efforts i can confirm
that the uk is
the first country in the world to have a
clinically
approved coronavirus vaccine for supply
and now our task is to make use of the
fruits of this scientific endeavor to
save
lives mr speaker we've spent months
preparing for this day
so that as soon as we got the green
light we would be ready to go
we were the first country in the world
to pre-order supplies of this
successful vaccine and we have 40
million doses pre-ordered for delivery
over the coming months enough for 20
million people because two jabs
are required for each following
authorization
the next stage is to test each batch of
the vaccine for safety
and i can confirm that batch testing has
been completed this morning for the
first deployment of 800 000 doses of the
vaccine
these doses are for the whole united
kingdom
this morning i chaired a meeting of
health ministers from the devolved
administrations to ensure
the rollout is coordinated nationwide
this will be one of the biggest civilian
logistical efforts that we've faced as a
nation
it will be difficult there will be
challenges and complications
but i know that the nhs is equal to the
task
rolling out the vaccine free at the
point of delivery
according to clinical need not ability
to pay
is in the finest tradition of our
national health service
and i'm delighted to confirm that the
nhs will be able to start vaccinating
from
early next week the whole purpose of the
vaccine
is to protect people from covid so we
can get lives back to normal so we will
prioritize the groups who are at
greatest risk
this morning the joint committee on
vaccination and immunization has
published its advice
setting out the order of priority
according to that clinical need
and this includes the care home
residents and their carers
the over 80s the frontline health and
social care workers
and we will deliver according to
clinical prioritization
and operational necessity because of the
need to hold the vaccine
at minus 70 to make it makes this
vaccine particularly challenging
to deploy and while we begin vaccination
next week
the bulk of the vaccinations will be in
the new year but i would urge
anyone called forward for vaccination by
the nhs
to respond quickly to protect themselves
their loved ones
and their community mr speaker over the
next few months we will see vaccines
delivered in three different ways
first we will begin vaccinations in
hospital hubs
second will deploy through local
community services including gps and in
due course pharmacies too
and third we'll stand up vaccination
centers in conference centers and sports
venues
for example to vaccinate large numbers
of people as more vaccines come on
stream
this is an important step but we are not
there yet and so i want to stress
that we must all keep playing our part
keep following the new rules that the
house approved overwhelmingly yesterday
and remember the basics like hands face
space
and get a test that we know from
experience are so
important in keeping the virus under
control
before i finish mr speaker may i also
update the house on another bit of good
news
from today i'm absolutely thrilled to
say that we can
safely allow visits in care homes for
those who test negative for covid19
coronavirus has denied so many people
the simple pleasure of seeing a loved
one which is so
precious to so many especially in our
care homes
this is only possible because of the
success we've had
in building one of the biggest testing
capacities in europe
and working with local and national
teams
working together side by side something
we've often discussed
right across this house we've worked
hard on testing
we've worked hard on the vaccine our
strategy of suppressing the virus until
our vaccine can make us safe
that strategy is working and i'm
delighted
that we'll be able to see families and
friends come together
ahead of christmas thanks to this
improvement
mr speaker this is a day to remember
frankly in a year to forget we can see
the way out of this but we're not there
yet
so let's keep our resolve keep doing our
bit to keep people safe
until science can make us free shall the
secretary
uh thank you mr speaker and as always i
thank the secretary of state for advance
site of his statement
this is indeed fantastic news about the
pfizer
vaccine and i want to join with the
secretary of state in congratulating all
who have been
involved in making this happen we have
rightly clapped
carers throughout this crisis mr speaker
i wonder if we should as a nation come
together
and applaud our scientists as well one
evening
and is also incumbent upon all of us
across this house
to reinforce the case that vaccination
saves lives and if it helps
i will stand alongside the secretary of
state
socially distanced of course on any
platform or any or in any tv studio
to show that we are united cross party
in promoting vaccination now mr speaker
our constituents will have legitimate
questions
and they shouldn't be uh ridiculed for
asking
legitimate questions so will he launch a
large-scale public information campaign
to answer questions and encourage uptake
will he consider sending a pamphlet
perhaps to every household
now we know that dangerous myths
circulate on social media and we again
we repeat our offer to work with
ministers
to curb online harms and i hope we can
work together and take something forward
on that front
hospital trust staff will start
receiving this vaccine
first i understand it's a massive
logistical exercise given that
the temperatures and the need for two
doses but could he tell us
how many how many nhs staff he expects
to be vaccinated
uh by january of course the time when we
expect the nhs one to be under to be
under most pressure
but also where does this leave social
care and
care home residents and staff there are
concerns that this particular vaccine
cannot be moved multiple times to care
homes
so can the secretary of state set out
exactly how and when
care home residents will receive a
vaccine
and our constituents will want to know
when will primary care networks
start rolling out vaccination and when
will the mass vaccination centers
he's reported to the house start opening
in our communities now we have historic
strengths as a country with vaccination
but in recent years we've actually lost
our measles free status
because we know vaccination rates can be
lower in poorer and vulnerable
communities
and we know that covid has a
disproportional impact often in these
communities
so will he ensure there's a health
inequality strategy as well
in his vaccination campaign so black
minority ethnic groups and the poorest
and the vulnerable
don't miss out on this vaccine i think
we all
understand mr speaker that restrictions
will have to remain in place for some
time
but can he offer us a time frame or a
target
for when we we should expect to achieve
herd immunity
and life gets back to normal will he
consider publishing a route map
of what restrictions could be released
as vaccination rates
increase and in the meantime if someone
is vaccinated
will they still have to isolate if
contacted by test and trace
or are they now released from that
obligation just on mass testing very
quickly
mr speaker some directors of public
health have told me that the lateral
flow tests
are not licensed for door-to-door
testing in hotspots and therefore can
only be administered at sites
if that's correct can he resolve it if
it's not correct can he issue urgent
clarity
to directors of public health and in the
doc the government's document published
on monday
uh uh it suggests that local areas could
use mass testing as a freedom pass
could you outline to the house what that
means in practice will local areas
enforce rules
if some people what happens if some
people are able to follow can
have had the test and not have the test
in a particular area that is supposed to
be under
tier three and in the house yesterday
the prime minister suggested that people
may want to take advantage of mass
testing ahead of visiting their families
this christmas could he update the house
on whether that is the plan
and how will that be implemented we of
course welcome his news
on on care homes but many care homes
report that they'll need
resources to support the uh to support
this this testing
exercise will those resources uh be
in place and very finely mr speaker if
mass testing is to work in these
communities
people will need support to isolate
if they have found that they've got
covered when they are not feeling unwell
will they now expand the eligibility
criteria
for the 500 pound grant but this is a
good this is a good
news day and we should all pay tribute
to everybody who was involved we should
pay tribute to the scientists
and i say again we will work together to
make the case that vaccinations
save lives thank you very much
uh mr speaker mr speaker if i may the
the honourable gentleman
uh has um worked uh supportively and
constructively with the government
throughout this
pandemic and i pay tribute to the
approach that he's taken and that he
took again today i
stand with him in saying vaccinations
save lives
and if we can together encourage
anybody to to take a
uh a vaccine who may be hesitant
uh by uh appearing together and being uh
vaccinated together
then of course i'd be uh i'd be i'd be
happy
i'd be happy uh to do that i i
i recommend uh mr speaker that we have a
um
that we have a professional vaccinating
us of course um
uh i don't think i don't think he'd
trust me to do that
um the um he asked for a public
information campaign
and there will of course be a public
information campaign and he asks about
health inequalities which is a very
important consideration of course the
best thing
to support tackling health inequalities
is the fact we have a vaccine but we
absolutely need to
to to try to reach all parts and all
communities
across the whole country he asked how
many will be vaccinated by
january and while today brings more
certainty mr speaker
it doesn't end all uncertainties because
while we have eight hundred thousand
that have now passed the uh batch
testing um
the um uh the the total number that will
be manufactured
over this uh time frame is not yet known
because it's
all dependent on a manufacturing process
which which is complicated itself after
all this isn't a
chemical it's a biological product and
so i can't answer that question that is
as yet
unknowable he asked when the pcns and
the centers will open the answer is very
soon
we we have 50 hospital hubs
ready to go from next week the
pcns are also being stood up and
the centers which are the centers
outside of hospitals
uh and these are all coming very soon
um he then asks about when wills get to
lift restrictions and of course i
understand the not only why he
but almost everybody in the country
wants to know the answer to this
question which is
um how many people do you have to
vaccinate
before you can start lifting the
restrictions
and the answer to that is that while we
know that the
vaccine protects the you as an
individual
with a 95 efficacy we do not know the
impact of the vaccine on reducing the
transmission
because of the problem of asymptomatic
transmission which has been such
so so bedeviled our response to this uh
to this virus and made it so hard to
tackle
and therefore we don't know the answer
to that question
but what we will do is follow the same
five indicators that we were discussing
at length um yesterday
which are the indicators of the spread
of the of the
disease and we'll look at the cases
uh the hospitalizations um and of course
the number of people who die with covid
and we we would hope very much as we
vaccinate more and more vulnerable
people
that we will see those rates come down
and therefore we'll be able to
lift the uh the uh the the restrictions
and so we we will have to see
how the uh the vaccination program
impacts directly on the epidemic and
then of course move as swiftly as we
safely can to lift
the uh the restrictions that we all want
to see
gone um he asks about the point on the
um
the community testing of being licensed
from door to door i haven't heard that
problem
um and um i will make sure that i get
back not only to him but also to those
who raised it with him if he'll work
with me on that um it is
i'm a bit surprised um the the lateral
flow tests
um do need a professional to uh to
administer
currently although we hope uh that we
can move further than that
uh but they do but that could be in any
setting as far as i know so i'm a bit
surprised to hear that but
since it came from a public health
professional
uh i'll i'll dig into it uh further
finally he talked about the testing
prospectus that we launched
on monday we do hope to
to be able to use testing to to do more
things
that we wouldn't be able to do without
the testing in a way the visits to care
homes are an example of that
that is something that we now can safely
recommend that we couldn't recommend
before
so too is a test to release on
quarantine for people coming into this
country
and if there are further examples that
can be
safely done of this sort of enablement
of normal life
through the use of testing that can be
approved by a director of public health
and by the chief medical officer and his
team then we are very enthusiastic about
working with local areas to deliver that
on the ground there's lots of ideas out
there
and i would urge people to be creative
about how we can do this in a way that
enables some of the things that we love
to get going again but does so in a way
that also keeps people
safe that's what that part of the
testing prospectus was about
i'm very enthusiastic about it and look
forward to working with directors of
public health and with colleagues
because the prime minister also said
this
yesterday he said with this rollout of
mass testing and the availability of
these tests
we all as leaders in our local
communities have got a role
for promoting the role of mass testing
and i'm sure that there are communities
right across the country represented
in this house who can benefit from this
roll out
there's many people looking around the
chamber right now who have already
approached me
uh mr speaker not just in lancashire
and um and i will and i look forward to
working with colleagues right across
this house to promote this
public health message amongst all the
other important public health messages
that we have to
promote not least that if nhs the nhs
phones you up
or sends you a letter and says that the
uh there is a vaccination slot
open to you then just say yes
sir thank you mr speaker and can i
congratulate my right honourable friend
on uh this moment and the government
for the news about the fisa vaccine but
please can we
continue to have increased honesty about
what we still don't know that we don't
know how long the immunity will last we
don't even know
if you are vaccinated whether you can
still transmit the disease and of course
we don't know if tier 2 will actually
succeed in bringing the r rate down
and until we can answer those questions
we still need maximum effort behind
contact tracing and isolation of virus
spreaders
councils like essex need daily access to
all the positive cases recorded by nhs
test and trace
immediately and without delay in order
to make their own operations
effective so why are they having to wait
48 to 72 hours before they get the data
and what is the government going to do
to engage districts
and their community volunteer hubs to
help people to persuade
to persuade people to support answer to
support people
who still must isolate even if they have
been vaccinated
thank you very much mr speaker well
dealing with this pandemic has been
a case of dealing with uncertainty
in large degree and today we have more
certainty because we know that this
vaccine is safe
and effective but just as i was saying
to the on member opposite
that we don't know the effect of the
vaccine on transmission so we
as my right-hand friend says don't we
don't know the effect
of the vaccine um in terms of its
longevity how long
it will be effective for and he's quite
right about another part of
public health advice that we can all
play a part in as local representatives
and that is the engagement with
uh with contact tracing i will
i will write to him on the point about
the access to daily data
in essex of course we have to we have to
wait until the test result comes in
which can sometimes lead to a delay
even though the um even though now the
majority of tests that are done in
person
do come back within 24 hours but i agree
with him in principle
and let's make that reality in practice
let's head up to scotland with smp
spokesperson dr philippa whitford
dr wakeford thank you very much mr
speaker
as chair of the all party group on
vaccination i absolutely welcome the
authorization of the pfizer vaccine
and would echo the shadow secretary's
call for a public health campaign to
encourage uptake
it will naturally take some time before
it's widely available
so we all still need to stick to the
rules and ensure we can test
trace isolate and support all those
carrying the virus
last week the secretary of state claimed
the pilot project of mass testing in
liverpool
was responsible for driving down cases
despite the city having been under
lockdown
for much of the time lateral flow tests
miss up to 40 percent of cases so the
government's plan to use them to free
people
from isolation are causing concern among
many public health
and screening experts so when will the
formal assessment of the pilot be
published
and how can he justify already putting
out tenders
for 40 billion pounds of contracts
to extend this approach without
scientific evaluation
would it not be better to invest some of
this money in getting the traditional
test trace and isolate system working
properly
as six months on the circo and citadel
system
has still not improved and over 40
percent of contacts in england
are still not being informed they should
be isolating he doesn't often talk about
it but he knows it's not testing but
isolation
which actually stops the spread of the
virus
so if people who are carrying the virus
are not isolating
no amount of mass testing will stop its
spread
when i raised the king's college report
last week
that less than 20 percent of cases and
only 10 percent of contacts
were isolating the secretary of state
claimed the government has data
showing much higher compliance so can he
tell us the figures
for isolation rates for those with covid
and their contacts
people won't stay off work if it means
they can't feed their family
so is he concerned at reports that many
requests for the isolation payment
are being refused and how will he ensure
that those carrying the virus are
financially supported
to isolate and reduce its spread
hey thanks very much well um the uh
the honourable lady uh says that i don't
talk about contact racing very much i
was just
literally answering a question on
contact tracing and the previous
uh intervention mr speaker i talk of
little else
um the um she asks also about the
questions
she'll we are publishing further uh data
tomorrow on contact tracing
uh precisely in response to the question
uh that she asked and
she'll see that the continued
improvement of our contact racing
across the country is um
is advancing further and we'll see that
in the
uh i can't say any more than that
because the figures aren't released
until
tomorrow she asked about scientific
evaluation and absolutely we're
constantly scientifically evaluating
the work that's going on especially in
liverpool that's one of the things that
the scientists who work as part of my
team and who work in nhs tests and trace
and work in public health england that's
one of the things they do
it's a matter of constant scientific
evaluation but what we won't do
is is is wait
ages after something has finished to to
then do a
uh an overly long evaluation what we do
is we have to evaluate as we're going
along
and we have to do that because we're
constantly trying to improve the
response to this
to this pandemic and we're constantly
trying to learn
and i would urge her to support the
approach of constant
learning and constant improvement we're
going to have to do that through the
rollout of the vaccine too
she shakes her head but that's how you
have to deal with a pandemic in practice
to the slight committee jeremy hunt mr
speaker this is a huge
personal triumph for the health
secretary who's always backed the
science
and in choosing and backing on behalf of
the country
the first vaccine to prove efficacious
he has scored a massive goal for the
country he deserves great
credit for that and it will also have
global significance
i was in a meeting with world health
organization this morning who
congratulated the uk on being the first
country
to approve a vaccine because it will
help encourage other countries around
the world
to approve vaccines faster i want to ask
him if i may
about something different which is the
plight of people with learning
disabilities he will know that public
health england
say that they are two to four times more
likely to
die from covid and the news that he's
given this morning about people in care
homes is tremendously welcome
but people with learning disabilities
often feel that they
are forgotten particularly if they're in
supported accommodation
and i wonder whether he could redouble
his efforts to make sure that they too
are able to be reunited with their
families ahead of christmas
well my right honourable friend is is
gracious and kind in
what he says um and i welcome the
comments from the world health
organization
this morning uh who've supported the uk
approach
and commended rightly the mhra
our independent regulator who have
followed
all of the same steps that any regulator
any high quality regulator would and
should
and will but what they've done is done
them rapidly and sometimes in parallel
instead of one after the other and
that's how we've got to the position of
being the first country in the world
to have a vaccine that is clinically
authorized
it's because the mhra has done a
brilliant job working with pfizer and
beyond tech
to make sure the same safety
considerations
are looked at but they're looked at in a
way that
essentially made the process as fast as
is feasibly and safely
possible and the who has backed that
approach
and i think regulators around the world
could take a look at the mhra
and we should all congratulate them he
rightly asked about
making sure that we vaccinate the those
with
learning disabilities and offer them
vaccination
at the right point in the prioritization
this is an important consideration
that i've discussed directly with the
jcvi who take into account
the higher mortality of those with any
given condition
and have done that within the
prioritization that they set out this
morning
and age is the single biggest
determinant of
mortality from coronavirus that's why
age is the predominant factor
in the prioritization but it's not the
only factor
and so that has been considered by the
jcvi and i think it's very important
that we
accept and follow the jdcvi advice as
much as is practicable
in the delivery and deployments of this
vaccine minera wilson
thank you madam deputy speaker and it is
indeed a fantastic day
and could i add my thanks and
congratulations to everybody who's been
involved in getting us to this point not
just in the uk
but worldwide because this is a great
example of global scientific
collaboration
could i pick up the point about batch
testing the secretary of state mentioned
it on the radio this morning and in his
statement
could he clarify that if we signed up to
a mutual recognition agreement
uh with the eu then we wouldn't need to
batch test
the vaccine again once it arrives in the
uk
which could perhaps slow down the
process not least because
um in terms of having enough qualified
persons who can do the batch release
testing
could be a real challenge so is he
working on a mutual recognition
agreement
thank you very much well we have that
mutual recognition agreement in place
uh now that she's right to point to the
global scientific work you know work
between
um uk scientists and scientists based in
the uk
of course german scientists at uh
beyond tech the american scientists and
the belgians
who are producing and manufacturing uh
this vaccine it is a
it is a it is a um an approach
that has been about people coming
together right around the world and the
uk has put
more into the global search for a
vaccine in cash terms than any other
country
despite our medium size as a nation
we have been the most generous and uh
i'm i'm really proud of that lee
anderson
thank you madam deputy speaker it's
great news about the vaccine and on
behalf of the
residents of asheville with a big thanks
to the health secretary the scientists
and the pharmaceutical
pharmaceutical companies the small
businesses in ashford and eastwood
have taken a massive financial hit
during lockdown despite doing their very
best
to be covered secure meanwhile
supermarkets have recorded record
profits
i've received lots of complaints this
week from customers and
staff at local supermarkets who say the
stores are overcrowded
and not curved safe and this is
happening all over the country and is
unfair
to the small businesses who have been
hit the hardest so whilst the uk
is being vaccinated in the run up to
christmas traders in my constituency
will do their very best
to beat the virus so could my right
honourable friend please remind the
supermarket executives
that they have a duty to protect their
staff customers our nhs and the whole of
the uk
in order to beat the virus and get our
lives back
yes madam deputy speaker i'm very happy
to
remind from this dispatch box the the
supermarkets of their responsibilities
to follow covert secure guidelines and
ensure they're in place for their
customers and their staff
and i also want to pay tribute to the
honourable gentleman for standing up for
the small businesses of ashfield it is
tough in ashfield at the moment
i get that we have the restrictions in
place only because they
are absolutely necessary and i know that
he understands that
and he's a strong voice for the small
businesses of asheville and indeed
uh all the residents of ashfield in this
chamber
jim shannon at this figure can i also uh
uh what a joy it was to see in the news
at seven o'clock this morning the the
news being broken and see the
the secretary of state as well i'd like
to put on record my thanks to the
secretary of state and all his team
for making this happen and thank you um
is the city to stay aware that there are
still those who
are unable to access their flu vaccine
what steps have been taken to ensure
that the flu vaccine rollout is
completed before the corona
program begins and what discussions has
the second state have with the northern
ireland summary to provide vaccines and
more importantly partly
the rollout for our vulnerable and
frontline key workers
thank you well i'm i'm grateful to the
honourable gentleman for his kind words
and it has been a big team effort um and
um
i i echo his uh thanks to the whole team
on the flu vaccine
and we have a further uh tranche of flu
vaccine
ready to go uh and that's just about to
be rolled out
and making sure that we get flu vaccine
available right across the uk
is very important it's an issue that
robin swan my opposite number
in the northern ireland administration
has and i have worked on extensively
and he is incredibly diligent in
ensuring that we get the flu vaccine
rolled out to the uh to
northern ireland um and um there is an
interaction between
of course the massive flu vaccine
rollout program which the nhs does every
year but this year is bigger than ever
and at the same time having to do a a
covert vaccine
roll out we've taken that into account
uh in the plans and in fact i was
before the announcement at 6 30 this
morning i was talking to
robert swan on the phone which shows how
hard work he is
the health secretary matt hancock
addressing the house of commons there on
what he described as a day to remember
in a year to forget he confirmed that
britain has tested the first batch
of 800 000 doses of the newly approved
pfizer biontech vaccine batch testing
completed this morning
ready for rollout early next week we
know from the scottish first minister
nicolas sturgeon that scotland will be
administering the first vaccine on
tuesday of next week but it won't be
easy the health secretary saying that
the rollout of the vaccine will be one
of the biggest
civilian logistical efforts that we've
faced as
a nation it will be difficult there will
be challenges and
complications but i know that the nhs is
equal
to the task we will deliver according to
clinical prioritization
and operational necessity because of the
need to hold the vaccine at minus
70. it makes this vaccine particularly
challenging
to deploy despite that confirming that
care home residents
and their carers will be first in line
for the vaccine
well earlier the prime minister boris
johnson urged everyone in the country to
have a covid19 jab after the uk became
the first in the world
to approve a vaccine regulators gave the
green light to the pfizer biontech jab
this morning and rollout will begin as
early as next week
i know that the whole house will want to
join me
in welcoming the fantastic news that the
mhra
has formally authorized the pfizer
vaccine for covid19
the vaccine i will begin to be made
available across the uk
from next week i would like to pay
tribute to and to thank all those who
have made this possible
it is the protection of vaccines that
will ultimately
allow us to reclaim our lives and get
our economy moving again i strongly urge
people to to take up the vaccine but it
is no part of our
culture or our ambition in this country
to make vaccines
mandatory that's not how we do things
studies show the pfizer biontech vaccine
is up to 95
effective and works across all age
groups
the uk has ordered 40 million doses of
it already which is enough to vaccinate
20 million people because two doses are
needed around 10 million doses are
expected to be available to roll out
in the coming weeks with 800 000 doses
available from next week for priority
groups the challenge is going to be how
to distribute it and store it
this is the vaccine of course which
needs to be kept at minus 70 to minus 80
degrees
however it does remain stable for a
limited time at between
two and eight degrees allowing for it to
be taken to
distribution centers well earlier
biontech's co-founder and chief medical
officer gave
a news conference in germany with this
update on the expected time frame
we called our development program for a
covet 19
vaccine project light speed because you
can't
go faster than light and this was what
we
aimed for this journey started in
january this year and was devoted
to the development of an uh well
tolerated
and effective covet 19 vaccine following
the highest
scientific and ethical standards
live to westminster now in our political
correspondent kate mccann good afternoon
to uk it is a good day and some welcome
and news not least for the government
after a bruising day yesterday
that's right it is and both boris
johnson and the health secretary matt
hancock have said so just
moments ago in prime minister's
questions and in the chamber for a
question
on the rollout of this vaccine but both
men also making clear that this is just
the start of something that will be a
very complex
and very difficult process to roll out
the vaccine to everyone who
needs it in the country over the coming
months it also will not happen
quickly and so the prime minister in
pmq's was very keen to point out that
people shouldn't ignore the new tier
system which comes into place today they
shouldn't let up
on following some of those restrictions
that we've all found so difficult over
the last year or so
he's very keen that people don't start
to change their
ways of living to ignore what the
government has been asking them to do
for so long because of course
there is no evidence at the moment that
this vaccine will stop transmission it
will protect you
but it might not stop you from
transmitting the virus matt hancock said
that just before in the house of commons
and that really is crucial because
what that tells you is the government
doesn't have a level of
a number of people that need to be
vaccinated which makes the rest of the
population
safe they are going to have to roll this
vaccine out to every single person
that they can get over the coming months
and that's going to take time
it's going to take careful planning and
it will not just be this vaccine there
are of course
others that the uk government has got
doses of
so it's going to be a careful process
and i think today while you say that it
is
obviously optimistic and that people
should feel a sense of relief if you
like that there is a vaccine coming and
that there will be
changes that we won't have to be like
this forever it's not going to happen
quickly those in care homes will be
prioritized those who are caring for
them too
and then by age range and it's when we
get to the sixth point on that
distribution priority list if you like
when we get to people who have
cancers long-term conditions other
things that may make them more
vulnerable to the virus so they may well
have to wait quite a time too
so it's not going to be an easy couple
of months although it is positive news
and of course
pfizer biontech have said a lot this
morning and the regulator about how this
process has been sped up
the fact that it is very safe there is
now a few calls actually to boris
johnson
to issue a communication strategy so
that all mps and those in the public eye
can be saying the same thing to the
public over the coming weeks because it
will be absolutely essential
that people feel safe they're able to
take the vaccine and
that they do take it when they are asked
to do so that will be the next crucial
stage
of trying to ensure that the uk can
recover from this pandemic
kate thank you let's speak to skies at
roland manthorp
and now and roland at the uk first
to approve a vaccine but what happens
next in terms of getting it to
this roll out early next week
well we were just on a call with pfizer
and they told us that the vaccine will
be here
by this weekend and i think we can
expect to see the verse the first
vaccinations next week and it is just
worth
pausing to think what a remarkable
achievement that is i mean
even as as recently as june or july
having a vaccine in december seemed
almost impossibly optimistic
and yet here we are and the target
from pfizer and biontech is to do 1.3
billion vaccines next year
and that's just one vaccine we've got
others on the way
i think that what we've seen here or
today
shows that the planning for this has
been in place for quite a long time
we've had a number of briefings from the
regulator from the vaccine committee
laying out who's going to get vaccinated
from the company and then from the pm
and
they were all saying pretty much what we
expected them to say
we've got used to briefings which are
chaotic and drama filled and you know
which honestly sometimes arrive late and
have very confusing slides
this was none of that they were a little
bit dull wonderfully dull
you might say because everyone was
singing from the same
hymn sheet the company was saying yes
we've got all the material